so you guys aren't aware Keith Lee is a
food blogger basically he's got a very
popular Tik Tok account where he does
reviews of restaurants most of them
black own but he does some other ones
and essentially goes in there and he
tries to review the food and it's very
popular because people really trust his
advice he does so in a kind of dead pan
very neutral kind of way and you know he
always does it with a mostly positive
spin so you know a lot of people like
his stuff anyways he was in Atlanta
recently and he had some bad things to
say about some of the Atlanta
restaurants because the service was
really poor which a lot of other Atlanta
residents also Echo but people had
issues with the fact that he gave bad
reviews saying it was ruining businesses
etc etc mind you he does all of his
reviews pretty anonymously he'll send
his family to go into the restaurant to
grab the food and in the parking lot he
tries it so that none of them know he's
a food reviewer so that's how he gets
honest interactions he doesn't want
special treatment he W walk in and be
all bougie that's how you're supposed to
interact which I respect I respect the
method meth methodology okay so shanon
sharp and Chad Johnson which are two NFL
Hall of Famers in my opinion definitely
Shannon sharp Chad Chad Johnson I mean
ooo I think should be in there they have
they have a podcast and they were
discussing it and it got pretty heated
so let's hear what they got to say oh I
got heated and the big question is
should these people be leaving bad
reviews which can negatively impact the
restaurants one and two it's especially
bad because you're doing it to your
other black people okay those are two
things to keep in mind let's watch I
don't know I don't know how often you've
been to Atlanta but the Atlanta food
scene we we we unique because a lot of
times it's all about dressing up and
it's it is it's an hour hour and a half
two hours two and a half hour wait time
a lot of time oo you got to eat a meal
before you actually go to the restaurant
because you gonna be hungry damn again
before you actually get in the
restaurant so it's perfect and look I
don't want people to think what's going
on is unique to Atlanta and black
restaurants normally oo you know this
from being a perform a professional
athlete we get privileges sometimes at
the restaurant and sometimes we get to
get things that normal people don't get
it
happens I don't like it Oho so you never
you've never got in the table because
you oo I'm not talking about that yeah
yeah and when when they do when they do
and you know me you know how I move and
everybody in this chat knows how I move
when I go to restaurants if you see me
first you understand what's coming at
the end when it's time to tip I've been
doing that 20 some years okay I like the
fact of what he's
doing I don't like I don't like it I
don't like the critiquing of our
restaurants and and having people and
and and and talking bad about our
goddamn businesses and how we going to
know how you supposed to do you you know
you're doing good or doing bad if if
that's not critiquing
critique gives you an average of which
it gives you
feedback that's how that's how I get
better feedback when I go in my office
and I construct a joke and I take that
joke and I go do
it what makes me do that joke again is
the feedback that people give you the
laughs as the feedback we need feedback
that's how we're supposed to go so
because he's because he has a platform
he's not supposed to give feedback no
more because he can influence the whole
purpose of having comment and rating
system online is that whether you're big
or not it affects your rating and people
are going to judge on that like you know
how hard you know how hard is for us to
even get in the food industry and to
have our own restaurant and so what are
we doing don't ask me don't ask me to
come to your house and then ask me what
I think about it without giving me
asking me to give you my honest
opinion nobody
ask a lot of these people listen a lot
of these a lot of these restaurants do
DM him ask him to come but he wants to
go a lot of times he wants to go
unannounced and give people that's what
he is he's a food critic he's turned
himself into a food critic it's okay are
we turn resume what are the qualif what
what are the qualifications of being a
food critic having taste buds cherry on
and Common Sense stop oo stop stop you
don't like the fact that it's degrading
black people because it's hard for us to
get in that business and I understand
and I concur it's hard for us to get in
that business and once we get there yo
we got to stve we got to do our thing
hence the reason why we shouldn't [__]
on customer and give back customer
service to me that's doing that to
ourselves we are the main people that do
that to ourselves when we give bad B bad
bad service when we talk to people like
we don't need them that we don't care
and like they're beneath us when they
are in our to be fair the worst service
I ever got was at Chinese restaurants
not even close me personally but I dig
rest sure absolutely oh I I I agree just
say I agree are are Chinese people
catching straights right now yeah but I
got to do it you're no you're right yeah
yeah I just think you
mostly but those restaurant that get
there if they get a bad revieww they get
a bad review the thing is with Chinese
people they have so much of the PE like
their people supporting them that they
don't care go to a restaurant and do you
like the food did you like the customer
service what was it like yes what was
the weight time like that's all you got
to
do how about go do that at mik Ros go do
that [__] at Chris roof go do it at poy
State go do it at [__] Zuma so again
he doesn't have an issue with what he's
doing per se he has an issue with doing
it with black black people which it's
interesting but let's keep listening go
do it to Day restaurants and give them
the bad press and the bad all the
o oo o oo oo because you're black
doesn't mean you're above criticism I'm
not saying you above anything but go go
do it there it's it's hard enough for us
as it is now here you go so in other
words so if he got bad service he
supposed to just let that slide service
wasn't bad service bad because it wasn't
it wasn't I ain't never had bad service
even if the service was bad they might
be having a bad day because some of the
goddamn idiots they don't have to deal
with honestly and the customer service
business you can't have a bad day
because think about what you just said
customer service do you know what it's
like dealing with some of these people
you shouldn't got in that business do
not get into the customer service
business if you could be easily
perturbed by having a bad day but
sometimes you need a job and sometimes
that job being customer service and
being in the Food Industries is all you
can do okay so his arguments is all over
the place making all kinds of excuses
for the fact going treating the
customers but it's just it's not it's
not a way you do things I'll say this um
as far as I'm concerned I don't like the
L idea of like if it's a black person
you got to watch what you say or
anything like that because then what's
the value of your review if you're just
going to always be positive then I'm
like well I know I've been to bad
restaurants how come you have it so why
would I trust this reviewer who always
only has positive things to say cuz then
I don't trust him cuz if he leads me to
a restaurant with a bad review or with a
good review that's not real and I have a
bad experience I'm like those guys are
fraud he probably bought and paid for so
your honesty in this whole matter really
matters okay you have to make sure that
you have some level of Integrity you
have to be impartial and if you do that
you're actually the opposite of that
exactly so there's a certain level of
that that I that you have to expect if
you don't have it you're just going to
ruin it for everyone I also say this
this whole mentality is often times like
what leads people to ask for handouts
what leads people to ask for favors that
are probably not deserve life I don't
know it's one of those things where it's
like sometimes you just feel like your
own people don't value what you do they
don't they just expect it because you
share the same skin it's like no the
same way I don't want to be treated like
crazy or like some royalty when I go to
your restaurant or anything that I just
want to be treated properly I don't want
you to start asking me to do things for
free because of that and essentially
what this what oo is asking is that
these people do Free Press for these
people without them actually deserving
it it hurts our economy it hurts the
reputation of the people who do the
reviewing and it's just bad for everyone
involved so I just don't like that kind
of mindset um and I I also just don't
think it's good for the business and the
over overall progress of the group when
you were playing in the NFL people were
not
not lighter on you on your case because
you're black it's so hard to be black
and it no you're good or you're bad true
you get a good review you get a good if
you caught that pass you caught that
pass I'm not going to [__] on the white
players because they're white and I'm a
I'm a I'm a black uh coach so I can't
[__] on my no I'm impartial and we're
here for the team you winning or you
losing now you deci side of that
business you get to work and that's that
what do he say let us know what you guys
think in the comments